Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Factorio. It works. *laughs* My GOD!
Bob: It FUCKING works!
Mark: So... Let me explain everything here. The inner loop...
Bob: So much better than mine.
Yea. *laughs* Let's just do a quick comparison between the two...Hm.
Bob: It's just...Hey I just got some science out of there! There's some science going on.
Mark: Yeah, there's some science, even though it's totally clogged right now. Can't do anything.
Mark: But...
Bob: It's fine.
Mark: Ok, so the basis of this is the idea that the...
Mark: The outer loop is entirely based on making science.
Mark: That's the only thing it's for except for the c... like, the conveyor system
Mark: It needs an input, but it gets input from an outside source, and then the gears
Mark: are placed on the inner loop. Now, this actually... I'm actually going to expand this,
Mark: because this can make MORE. This can do more, this can make more science than this
Mark: because there is an abundance of material on the outside of the loop
Mark: so I'm gonna get more copper... HOLY shit. (ho, shit) *nervous laughter* The lag is still a little bit weird.
Mark: like, I dunno why the lag's happening, 'cause we switched, now I'm hosting the game.
Bob : *laughs
Mark: but for some reason...
Mark: there's still some weird lag
Bob : Still laggy!
Mark: But I'm gonna, I'm gonna live with it, because this is sooo cool, it's so cool! *laughs*
Mark: Ah, god damnit, I keep going into the woods when I wanna stop
Mark: Okay
Mark: So I just need some more iron and copper *inhale*
Mark: and then I'm going to make... more assembly machines, and then put them on the outside loop
Mark: on the bottom side, because there's plenty of space down there, I can
Mark: I can actually expand a loop out of it more, and then...
Mark: we will have... glorious, GLORIOUS capacity.
Mark: We will have sooo much science being produced.
Mark: Now what ha-
Bob: So many capacities
Mark: Yeah, but now,
Mark: I know there's a science pack 3 and a science pack 4
Mark: and I don't even WANNA know what the assembly loop's gonna look like for that son-of-a-bitch
Bob: *laughs*
Mark : Like, my god.
Bob: I'm sure it's gonna be just as efficiently built.
Mark: Wait a minute, that's not right... Why is the inside... [brain melts]
Mark: Why is the inside clogged up with -uhhh- with, uuuhhh... [brain still melting]
Mark: Why's the inside clogged up? It shouldn't be clogged up? [Utter confusion]
Mark: Why's the inside clo-
Bob: You're asking like I know...
Mark: It's just clogged up with gears!
Mark: Oh, that's right, because I needed an output filter of gears. I, I, I needed that - umm...
Mark: One last thing for this is the... uh... overflow, because gears always overflow
Mark: There's always like too many of 'em, so, after...
Bob: Mmh
Mark: all of the production need- that need gears, grabs gears
Mark: I have a smart filter filter out gears, so that any excess gears get put in a box.
Bob: Oh, so you just need another smart grabber on the outside filtering out gears.
Mark: No, no! Inside, inside, the inside line is only dedicated to gears, so it's fine that that gear is full.
Mark: Ideally, the inner loop would also have gears only being placed on the inside
Mark: And, but that, that'd be really freaking hard to do...
Mark: Oh, I just had a brainwave.
Mark: on how to do that
Bob: Let's just-
Mark: Aaah!
Bob: Do that thing you just though of.
Mark: I, I, I could have these two up here
Mark: instead of these both dedicating to the outside loop, I could have them both where I'm standing
Mark: And then one puts it on the outside loop and one puts it on the inside loop, 'cause...
Mark: No, if... Yeah, if I moved one down, then I could put the gears on the inside of the inside loop,
Mark: where nothing is, currently, because it's out of materials.
Bob: Why does the outside of the outside loop all jammed up?
Mark: Uh, because it needs more science production, that's whu- that's what I was about to do.
Mark: Um, so, on this bottom line, I'm literally gonna put down way more, uhh, science doodads? So watch this -
Bob: Right, so it only needs, it doesn't need both of these transporter things, so you can set this one to science too, then.
Mark: Uhhhh...
Bob: That's what that means, right?
Mark: True, but let me put these down
Mark: To see if we can get enough here, because we MAY have prematurely celebrated the whole "it works" thing
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: Like...
Bob: Yeah, totally works
Bob: No one-No one look into it! It works just fine!
Mark: Bob, you're always standing exactly where I wanna put something...
Mark: Okay, there we go
Bob: I'll just continuously move around, so at least I'll only be in the way
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: for a brief moment
Mark: But then you'd just end up being everywhere in my way
Mark: And I can't possibly get anything done.
Bob: *snickers*
Bob: *Snickers*
Mark: *Also snickers*
Mark: Okay
Mark: So...
Mark: if these are all science
Mark: these are all science
Mark: These are aaaaaallllll science
Mark: Okay Cool.
Mark: Good Job Bob!
Mark: Good job Igor Bob!
Bob: I HELPED!
Mark: You helped
Bob: *dark semi-raspy voice* I HELPED.
Mark: *laughs*
Bob:  Did it!
Mark: *raspy voice* Yes Master.
Mark: DEDEDELELE
Bob: What is that 6?
Bob: 2...?
Bob: Oh shi-
Bob: Snikies!
Bob: I just shift clicked.
Bob: On the manufacturing tab
Bob: and made 73
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: inserters.
Mark: Good enough!
Mark: That's good enough for anybody.
Mark: Okay so
Bob: Alright
Bob: I got all your
Bob: Oh you got all your inserters already
Mark: Yeah
Mark: I'm trying to make it symetrical
Mark: SO DON'T EVEN TOUCH ANYTHING
Mark: it's going to be BEAUTIFUL
Mark: hang on I gotta-
Bob: WOP
Mark: no
Mark: NO
Bob: WOP
Mark: NOO!
Bob: HEY I DID IT!
Mark: Damn it Bob
Mark: You did it perfectly.
Mark: I can't even c-
Bob: I DID IT!
Mark: You did it.
Mark: Good Job.
Bob: Did EXACTLY what your brain wanted.
Mark: Thank you Bob, you are a delight-
Bob: I'M A GODDAMN GENIUS!
Mark: Well, okay Bob. Let's--
Bob: Don't take this away from me.
Mark: Yeah.
BOB: I'M THE BEST!
Mark: Well okay, um
*clearly not giving a shit*
Bob: Don't-
Bob: Don't take this away from me..
Mark: I wasn't gonna
Bob: I EARN-NED THIS.
Mark: You earn-ned this.
Mark: good job Bob you earn-ned.
Mark: Okay, so what I'm gonna do is also
Mark: have that do that-
Bob: I'm gonna put this extractor over here cuz
Mark: tuh la tuh la
Bob: science.
Mark: tuh la tuh la tuh
Mark: tadadadata
Mark: no no don't put my
Mark: NOOO
Mark: NOOOO
Mark: NOOOOOOO, LAG!
Mark: Okay there we go.
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: so
Mark: alright
Mark: so this is good.
Mark: like, good call on only one transporter belt production
Mark: because that's important
Mark: and now
Mark: the outside loop is getting fed with plenty of
Mark: is there anything choking up these-
no they're getting plenty of what they need
Bob: it seems so balanced, Mark
Mark: everything is cooool.
Bob: it's so balanced.
Mark: I just need to replace this with a faaast one.
Mark: and everything is GOOOOOCH
Bob: I just got a lot of science packs
Mark: nice hOW MANY?
Bob: I have a hundred and six in my inventory right now.
Mark: *evil dramatic cackling laughter*
Mark: Okay anyway
Bob: Okay, wicked witch of the Mark.
Mark: Alright, I may have gotten overly ambitious on making all these science things.
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: In fact I'm 100% certain that I went overboard on making all these science macines
Bob: Nah, it seems like it'll be fine. Science takes a long time to produce.
Mark: It does, you're right
Mark: BUT
Mark: I don't think... *sniff* I don't think
Mark: four inserter creators is going to be enough to make everything but it's cooooool.
Mark: why's it low on gears?
Mark: We not need to filter gears?
Bob: The inner part is low on gears huh?
Mark: Apparently.
Mark: I didn't even realize that was possible.
Mark: Okay
Bob: OH! The just 62 finished.
Mark: YAAY!
Bob: Now we can replace all these transporter belts with fast transporter belts
Mark: YAAAAAAAY!
Mark: WE DID HEHHEHEHEHEHE IT
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: YEAHAHAHAHAHAH!
Bob: I like how-
Mark: NOW I CAN CELEBRATE! :D
Mark: *sighs in relief*
Bob: - I'm just like the science officer
Mark: Ahh it's-
Bob: Don't worry I'll do all the research
Mark: Ahhh it's so nice.
Mark: well I mean I can't be trusted with actually thinking because y-you you saw how much brain power-
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: - is dedicated just to making this work
Mark: and barely is looping along
Mark: *sniff*
Mark: *very close to breaking down* but it's doing it
Mark: *sniffs*
Mark: it's a thing of beauty
Bob: yeah, it is it's doing it.
Mark: oh man, we just need a lot
Mark: we need a lot more inserter production
Mark: it's a bit slow on the inserter production but
Mark: if it could go faster
Mark: it hopefully would
Bob: just GO FASTER YOU INSERTER MOTHERFUCKERS
Mark: YEAH!
Mark: B-BIIIIITCH
Bob: B-B
Bob: B-
Bob: BITCH
Mark: B
Mark: B-B-BI
Mark: Bi-i-i-tch
Mark: hep-p b-uh
Mark: *slightly high pitched* Biiitch
Bob: I've honestly the only
Bob: -oh the gears on the outside are out of iron already.
Bob: awesome
Mark: yeah
Mark: we need a lot more iron production
Mark: which means we need to change those burners up up top to steel furnaces
Mark: I can actually make those. I'll make those steel furnaces.
Mark: cuz that'll double capacity-
Bob: I've got a lot of steel, do you need steel?
Mark: No no no
Bob: I've got like 7-
Mark: NO No no nonono nuh nunununu no
Mark: I've got lots of steel.
Bob: kay.
Mark: don't worry about steel.
Mark: let ME worry about steel.
Bob: Oh.
Bob: I actually have 7 stacks of steel so
Mark: nice.
Bob: still have steel.
Bob: Oh look at you
Mark: I know right?
Bob: Do steel furnaces go faster or-
Mark: They go twice as fast.
Bob: or they more efficient?
Bob: Sexy.
Mark: So basically
Mark: Now there shouldn't be a choke hold of this iron.
Mark: It should just be-
Bob: so now I can put some more iron
Bob: -kerjigigder or something here
Mark: Kerjigigders, yeah exactly
Mark: that's the technical term
Bob: low production on there-
Mark: some more ffffffffuckin' iron
Bob: - yeah
Mark: for the ffffffuckin' burners
Bob: no you don't gotta tell me 'bout the kerjigigders
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: I- I actually-
Bob: I KNOW ABOUT KERJIGGDERS
Mark: I actually know nothing about kerjigigders, so if you could explain that
Mark: scientifically speaking exactly we're talking about here because I am not clear.
Bob: Well, so okay, when you need something out of the what's-it-called
Bob: it's important to get the right type of kerjigigder, obviously
Mark: okay
Mark: alright
Bob: no one knows that
Mark: ah-uh obviously
Bob: and uh
[Mark's "I don't know what he's doing and I think we fucked up but let's just go with it." face]
Bob: and yeah, so
Bob: over here I looked and I was like, 'woah that's iron and it's the ground so'
Bob: I
Bob: it's these particular kind of kerjigders right here
Mark: Uh-huh.
Bob: see how they spin and they move back and forth
Mark: Yeah
Bob: It's-
Mark: I see that.
Bob: -crucial
Bob: for iron production
Mark: Okay good.
Bob: It's crucial
Mark: Of course yeah, I mean I should've known that but obviously you know better than I do
Bob: Everyone, everyone knows that Mark.
Mark: Okay, I DIDN'T at the moment, but now I do.
Mark: so thank you Professor Bob--
Bob: EVERYONE KNOWS THAT.
Mark: Yeah, Professor Bob
Bob: YEAH, EVERYONE KNOWS THAT.
Mark: yeah.
Bob: PhD.
Mark: Why do you have 2 smart filters filtering out the science?
Mark: *whispers* you don't need that much science.
Bob: cuz there was a lot of science goin' on
Bob: and it couldn't handle it
Mark: but there's not as much science now.
Bob: Yeah I know it was just a short term solution to a not problem
Mark: yeah
Mark: i-it busted it out because it was so backed up with all the inserters it was making, now it's barely keeping up with inserter production.
Mark: wait why is it- OH it's out of metal AGAAAIIN.
Bob: so maybe our next
Bob: One of our next strategy is we should get
Bob: Either set up iron production to the South
Bob: is there iron to the South?
Bob: yeah
Bob: maybe take advantage of this iron production and
Bob: Uhhh
Bob: is there coal down here, probably not huh.
Bob: there's a lot of iron
Mark: Hm.
Bob: there's not a lot of anything else
Bob: Maybe we should set up that iron production to the North, with some fast conveyer belts
Bob: and get some iron plates feeding down here automatically
Mark: That would be super cool, I like that thinking, that is radical
Mark: and I'm 100% on board
Bob: I'm not the best at designing things to go in directions
Bob: but you know I could try.
Mark: You could try, yeah
Mark: I-I think- I think you could do well. I think you could really well.
Mark: I think you've got a lot of potential-
Bob: If I really If I really put my mind into it
Mark: Yeah
Mark: I think I thhhhhiiiiink that's not actually not a bad idea because
Mark: that means
Mark: that
Mark: We'll have more than enough *scratches beard*
Bob: Alright so I'm gonna sort of free form this is that a good strategy?
Mark: Yeah usually whenever you're going after things that are scientific and important
Mark: wait where did you even go?
Mark: BOB?
Mark: oh there you are.
Mark: you like, blended in with the back ground.
Mark: Hi Bob! :D
Bob: Hey Buddy! :)
Mark: Hiiiiii
Mark: Okay so
Mark: Aaah
Mark: and then we can make-- yeah underground!
Bob: Yeah underground
Mark: UNDERGROUND!
Mark: YEAAAAAH!
Bob: No, I got it.
Bob: I got it BRO.
Bob: Don't-
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: Don't you worry about blank.
Bob: Let me worry about blank.
Mark: I get that reference.
Bob: Digididy!
Mark: I understand it. It's a good reference.
Bob: I DID IT!
Mark: YAAAY!
Mark: So now it can feed down, and we can get long handles to do the dirty work
Bob: Ah Fuck You, you fuckin wood
Bob: fuckin raw wood fuckin-
Mark: geez.
Bob: fuckin douchebag
Mark: sorry
Bob: give give Give Give GIVE GIVE
Mark: yeah yeah Yeah Yeah YEAH YEAH
Bob: Oh actually just- just to make it nice
Mark: Uh-huh
Bob: Underground, underneath our road for no reason
Mark: but I mean-- we could put more road, its--
Bob: SHUT UP MARK.
Bob: LOOK AT HOW NICE IT LOOKS
Mark: I guess *laughs*
Bob: LOOK HOW NICE IT LOOKS
Mark: *continues to die out of laughter*
Mark: I guess
Mark: okay
Bob: Just let me have this one.
Mark: I'm sorry
Mark: I'm sorry Bob
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: I'll never question your decisions again
Mark: you're a genius
Bob: Alright so now I have to actually think about
Bob: We need iron
Bob: here
Bob: and over to the left by those long handles
Bob: is there any other iron feeds that we need?
Mark: Yeah, there's an iron feed but it's impossible to get to
Mark: because on the inside
Bob: No Bro
Bob: Bro! Underground Bro!
Mark: OOHHHH YOU'RE RIGHT
Bob: UNDERGROUND BRO!
Mark: BOB I'M SO SORRY BOB
Mark: AGAIN WITH ME I'M JUST SO STUPID
Mark: *inhale*
Mark: I CAN'T DO ANYTHING RIGHT
Mark: EVEN IF-
Bob: You gotta have-
Mark: MY PARENTS DIDN'T WANT ME
Bob: You gotta have faith, man.
[preach Bob, preach.]
Mark: *sniff*
Mark: Okay
Bob: You gotta have
Bob: You gotta have faith
Mark: *on the verge of letting rivers flow from his eyes* Okay.
Bob: I
Bob: got this
Bob: don't you even worry.
Bob: alright this doesn't go that far.
Bob: nevermind.
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: Hang on
Bob: I'm still working it out.
Mark: Okay.
Bob: but I probably got this
Bob: nooooo prooblemooo
Mark: I-I Believe in you a hundred percent
Mark: Bob, you are the kingpin of every design choice in this world
Mark: and-
Bob: You are the wing beneath my wings, Mark
[AWW adorable :3]
Mark: Yes
Bob: thanks for backing me up on this one.
Mark: Yeah.
Mark: I uh and honestly
Mark: I- I love you
Mark: is like- I just want to clear that out loud
Mark: just because you know
Mark: haven't had the chance to say it properly
Mark: so just you know
Mark: *sniff*
[That's real friendship right there :')]
Mark: know that I feel in my heart
Mark: lot of LOVE
Bob: I feel it
Bob: Don't you worry about that I feel it
Bob: You know what's really gonna put the icing on the cake here
Bob: is when I uh make this a complete loop
Bob: so that it feeds itself like an unbelievable boss.
Mark: OOOOHHHHHHH FUUCCKK
Mark: I'm just adding a little more 'umpfh' to your
Mark: to your uh
Mark: ...metal
Bob: so
Bob: hang on
Mark: Cuz we got OODLES, OODLES
Bob: we got to think about these things
Mark: and oodles of production
Bob: Think about these things
Bob: I can do this
Mark: Okay.
Mark: I-I
Bob: I can do this..
Mark: Bob are you
Mark: are you saying I should doubt your ability?
Bob: No No No, I got this
Mark: cuz I was so unquestioning on everything that you were doing that at this point I-
Mark: I Dunno
Bob: Oh you know what?
Mark: Hm?
Bob: no that's not gonna work
Mark: Just to make it easier, I'm going to take this last one out of here
Mark: cuz
Mark: that actually make it-
Bob: OH! That would make it
Bob: are you taking that whole?
Bob: oh okay
Mark: Naw, I'm not taking-
Bob: Oh, Yeah-
Mark: -whole line, I'm just taking that outta here
Bob: LOOK AT YOU
Bob: Look at you, you just made my whole life-
Mark: YAAY!
Bob: NOW EVERYTHING MAKES SENSE AGAIN!
Mark: YEAHAHA!
Mark: I HELPED! :D
Mark: YEAAAH!
Bob: Mark, I knew you were here for some reason
Mark: *under a lot of happiness* OHO THAHANKS!
Mark: *sniff*
Mark: I just wanna mean something to you Bob!
[same here, Mark.]
Mark: I just wanna MEAN something
Bob: oh no I'm outta I'm outta roads
[nice priorities, Bob.]
Mark: Oh, I got it. You want me to finish
Mark: it up?
Bob: uh
Bob: You
Bob: You do whatever you want, Buddy.
Mark: Okay
Mark: Imma use a combination of underground and normal ground
Bob: Oh go for it
Mark: it's gonna be SEXY
[well.]
Mark: cuz there's an electric pole -
Bob: You- You just do it up
Mark: -in the way
Mark: and I can't- I can't get rid of that
Mark: so I gotta go-
Bob: no you need that-
Bob: that needs to be there, that was very carefully put there
Mark: I gotta go
Bob: It HAS to be there
Mark: underground~
Mark: YEAAAHHEHEHEHAHAA
Bob: OHHH FUCK
Mark: actually I'm gonn--
Bob: Oh shit we need some copper on this
Bob: too don't we?
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: wait fuck
Bob: *still laughing* just another thing
Bob: HEY! The copper's right here man!
Mark: wait uhh
Bob: it was right fucking here man
Mark: is it?
Bob: I could bring copper over here, NO PROBLEM MAN!
Mark: *in a weird tone* nO prOBlm' MAN!
Bob: NO PROBLEM AT ALL MAN!
Mark: *still in that weird tone* Da'am Man
Mark: *The Damn Daniel Tone* DAAAMN MAN
Mark: Okay that's goood
Mark: *Dramatic Gasp*
Mark: OOOHH IT WORKS
Bob: It's so pretty and..
Bob:...symmetrical
Mark: It's so so horrifying-
Bob: It's so BEAUTIFUL!
Bob: *as if almost forced* It looks amazing
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: I can't believe it!
Mark: I mean-
Bob: LOOK IT'S SO GOOD!
Mark: It's just
Mark: are you
Mark: are you making fun of me? is that what you're..
Bob: NO!
Bob: I'd just-
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: can't believe
Bob: that I
Bob: that I did that
Bob: I'd- I made that happen
Mark: You did-
Bob: It's ugly as un-
bob: -unbelievable fuck
Mark: *high pitched* WOW YOU KNOW
Bob: I made that happen.
Mark: It's not the ugliest thing in the world
Mark: It's not the ugliest thing I've ever seen
Mark: it's actually acceptable.
Mark: I'm okay with it.
Bob: can you put extra-
[again, nice priorities, Bob]
Bob: you put extra hand grabbers over here what are you doing to me?
Mark: well I- we needed more iron and it wasn't enough to feed everything
Bob: *sighs in sadness*
Mark: OH c-c'MOONN MAN!
Bob: whatever.
Mark: DON'T BE LIKE THAT! :(
Bob: Y-huh
Bob: You TOOK MY VICTORY!
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: also if you get that reference
Mark: I don't.
Bob: then we're best friends for a reason
Bob: awwwwww
Mark: there's this one grabber there that's doing a dance
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: It's literally
Mark: It's literally freaking the fuck out
Bob: Where where are you I don't see you
Mark: It's on the inside loop
Mark: by the gears.
Mark: It is freaking
Mark: the fuck out like
Mark: it's gonna grab one and then just
Mark: heh heh heh-
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: heh heh heh
Mark: heh
Mark: heeeeeeeh
Mark: heheheheh
*Both Mark and Bob laugh*
Mark: I DON'T KNOW IF I CAN
Bob: Reggie
Bob: We've talked about this
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: I think it's time for you to retire, man.
Mark: ah man.
Bob: I don't think you're moving as fast as you used to move
Bob: I don't-
Mark: there we go
Mark: I got the other guy going.
Bob: I know you need to provide for your family but-
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: Come on
Bob: Uh
Bob: uh
Bob: it's just
Mark: you're- you're well past retirement age, Reggie
Mark: like this is getting embarassing like you're a liability at the workplace now
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: *imitating Reggie* err but I can still do th--fucking do crap
Bob: *also imitating Reggie* arrgh I just need to get one more arm
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: *imitating Reggie* wait hang on- AH! I GOT IT!
Bob: *imitating Reggie* arrl- alright just need to get the next one, hang on!
Mark: *continues to die of laughter*
Bob: *imitating Reggie* DON'T WATCH ME YOU'RE MAKing me nervous..
mark: *still dying of laughter*
Bob: *imitating Reggie* I've been doing this for over 30 years
Mark: Yeah he thought I wouldn't notice, like he'd be safe on the inside away from everything else.
Mark: BUT I NOTICED REGGIE
Mark: WE GOT OUR EYES ON YOU
Mark: okay anyway
Mark: That is all the time we got for this episode, so
Mark: THANK YOU EVERYBODY SO MUCH FOR WATCHING
Mark: Thank you Bob, check out Bob's channel in link the description below
Mark: And as always
Mark: We'll see you
Mark: in the next video
FROM MARK AND BOB
[and the dudes who made the subtitles for this episode]
BUH- BYEE!
cue outro music